on this episode I talk about hot guys
and girls banter and Twitter's new
algorithm you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching episode number 34 of the
askgaryvee show
fun fact about the number 34 that is the
number that the oak tree
Charles Oakley wore during the 90s
Nick's my favorite squad of all time
other fun fact about Charles Oakley is
he punched a lot of people directly in
their face
Baroni asks you say to put out quality
content daily can I add curated content
to my own content if yes what's the
right mix the thanks so much for a great
first question I uh I'm really excited
by the way I've been really missing the
show between the weekend and traveling
to LA and st. Louis on Monday and
Tuesday big shout out to everybody who's
listening on the podcast oh I said
watching I didn't say watching and
listening on the intro that's just how
it is sometimes anyway ah the answer to
your question is absolutely as a matter
of fact I think what I call DJing the
ability to take content that's going on
all around the world right now and bring
it into your voice and putting it out
there is an enormous skill set I think
it's mapping what's happening in the
actual music world right you look at
what's happening in EDM and other places
that nature deejays people that are able
to take a lot of different things and
put them together it's really like being
a great chef isn't it so actually I
think one of my biggest weaknesses is my
lack of curation right because I take so
much pride that the content is mine I
haven't gone out and and taken you know
articles from other people and then like
you know kind of jumped on top of that I
remember loving tumblr one of the
reasons I invested in tumblr way back
when was the notion of reblogging right
like tumbling something you hit you hit
somebody else's blog post and then you
wrote your two cents on top of it the
retweet functionality with a quote of
and then you put your own two cents on
Twitter I think still has a lot more
potential they like limit you to room I
love the ability to retweet and then
have 140 characters and let the whole
thing be 250 characters Twitter you
should steal that
because I think that would make Twitter
much better I think the adding of two
cents has always been something that I
think has been valuable and you look at
somebody like Guy Kawasaki I mean if you
go look at his Twitter feed it's all
curation right he treats himself like a
media company it's almost not him it's
like the Guy Kawasaki you know a network
and he's just putting out hundreds of
tweets a day it feels like of just
different articles things of that nature
kind of like a human nuzzle or or kind
of like a human RSS feed so I think
curation of other people's stuff or or
passing on other headlines is the
biggest weakness in my social media
content game and I highly recommend all
of you working on it and if he feels
comfortable for a lot of people you know
I would say ma here comes a humble brag
but I've been doing a lot of that lately
if you can see the latest video uh I
like that dynamic pause don't of it uh
so for me I think the reason I don't do
as much curation is I have the ability
to do original content at scale that's a
struggle for a lot of people so for a
lot of people that don't know what to
say the curation of other content and
being the news source for somebody and
the rest of the world under there
context within their genre is you know
if you're a yoga person or a health
person or a pumpkin picker you know your
two cents on Apple pay or or George
Clooney's wedding or things that these
are under the context of being a puffle
punk pumpkin picker matters darren asks
how much sleep should you get on average
do you work seven days a week do you
have set days off to spend time with
family Darren you know this is a great
question I get asked a lot you know I
think I talked so much about hustle
people don't think I sleep I you know I
try to get six or seven hours of sleep I
think sleep is massively important for
the body right now I'm working out a lot
as you guys can tell and and that's
affecting my sleeping patterns not that
I sleep better by the way everybody
thought I'm so exhausted before I was
just sleeping like a rock I'm lucky with
the sleeping but I sleep quite a bit
that you know weekends are for the
family know this on the weekend anymore
for the last couple years a lot more
vacation time going from maybe a week or
two even as early as four or five years
ago to now then three or four now even
like five so sleeps important rest
who is important recharging is important
it's it's not about 365 days of complete
insanity it's about 265 days of complete
insanity and you know in a hundred days
of really resting and giving you the
energy to have that insanity I think
Hustle is about when you're in it versus
everyday doing it right so for me it's
this Tuesday of Wednesday see this
Wednesday is all in right like I'm going
to go all in the whole way every minute
a lot of people are around my life now
even you guys probably get very caught
off-guard of how I have zero minutes and
play for 15 hours in a day like there is
no Zack needs like two minutes to like
Hey look at this new design for Wine
Library and DeMeo
my assistants like yeah next Thursday
and he's like two minutes right I mean
like so I go all in on the days I'm in
but boy do I rest when I rest and boy do
I check out when I check out so ever I
don't even like travel I don't want to
see the pyramids or the Eiffel Tower I
don't care about the coral reefs when I
vacation I need to sleep on a beach and
don't talk to me that's how much
recharging when I sleep if you walked
into my home punched me directly in the
face and stabbed me with a knife in my
left arm while I was sleeping and robbed
everything in my home I'd still not wake
up that's how all in I am when I'm
resting so I'm just an all-in character
regardless of what I'm doing Corey asks
what have you found is the best way to
introduce non wine drinkers to wine
without it seeming overwhelming Coria
Corey I took this question because not
only for the wine people listening but
for the business people that are trying
to educate about social media or apps or
tech culture it's the same game why did
I over index in the wine world and why
do I think I over index in the business
marketing operation social media
marketing world I said marketing twice
because it's so nice it's because I talk
to people not down to them how do you
get people into your thing how do you do
that you talk to them to them not down
to them and that's what I'm really
that's the struggle for everybody who
gets any level of expertise they get
this expertise
they want to leverage it against their
audience to establish on here you're
here I fully believe and I can I can
guarantee the comments coming right now
that one of the reasons people watch and
listen to this show and have followed me
for the last seven years when I was
educating about wine intimidating
subject or social media new intimidating
subject to a lot of people is I'm
talking level set right I'm not imposing
my expertise I'm not making anybody feel
bad that they don't know as much as me
snickering like how could you ask me
this question Ricky I don't do that
right I understand that there's ninety
nine percent of the world that I know
jack crap about I know my couple little
things and when I'm trying to learn
about other things from other people
that no it's nice to be talked to at
that level which is respect as a human
being not being imposed on something you
learned a little bit more about and so
you want to get people into wine or
anything else for all of you that are
watching and I see a lot of you who are
watching trying to impose your expertise
on food or pets or anything of that
nature I highly recommend you start
realizing you're talking to somebody not
down to them Adam says I understand that
marketers ruin everything
but as Twitter's latest algorithm change
going to damage the user experience and
the essence of Twitter Adam Congrats on
getting on the show guys let's give a
huge shout out a collective shout out in
the comments and go on Twitter and give
him a shout out adam has Hasselt has
asked a lot of questions he has
persevered he's taken my advice from
some other episode recently where I just
said keep asking keep asking keep asking
he didn't give up a lot of you've given
up a lot of you have stopped using the
askgaryvee hashtag to try to get on the
show with your question because that 420
episode you didn't get on loser
mentality winner mentality is adam who
is completely over indexed on asking
over and over and over to get on the
show big props to you brother they
answer your question life is very simple
whether it's for Twitter showing you ads
or Facebook which is set this up for
Twitter because they're following that
notion of discovery whether it's dating
the most attractive guy or girl you've
ever dated before but they actually
aren't that nice of a person and you
actually just don't like them that much
it's more
guy thing from what I can tell for my
girlfriends but like that notion that
same psychology plays out on this answer
which is the world is predicated on the
value it's providing you versus what
it's doing to otherwise meaning what
without a dog if you're listening that
was not a dog ah from what we could tell
my friends it's very simple it's the
value proposition
it's a seesaw does it kill Twitter it
kills Twitter for the people that don't
value everything else that Twitter does
and find seven to ten more tweets in
their stream not valuable enough right
when when you're a young guy and you get
that hottest girl that you've ever dated
she's so pretty you don't care about
that she's like hurting your feelings
and mean to your friends and not letting
you hang out with your friends and all
you let that all go because you value
the beauty over that and as you evolve
eventually if she's the worst you can
finally after the beauty subsides and
you've calibrated the beauty you go the
other way and that's just the way it is
about life you love your family so much
that you let them get away with so much
that's the bottom line
Facebook has enough value in keeping up
with your friends and has a lot of data
to show you the stuff that you actually
want to see and that's why we're
tolerating it and you can tell me the
kids are going off of it and they're on
snapchat Instagram and so are you and
that's fine that makes sense but
Facebook's data shows the world it's
true there were still on it at enough
scale if Twitter's unable to do that or
any other product in the world tumblr
was very valuable to high school kids it
was a different creative place they
didn't make the shift to mobile fast
enough and good enough and they lost
their value proposition when something
else came along what happens when the
pretty girl with an awesome attitude
comes along and so the answer to this
question and you can see I've used human
kind of like what we all grew up with
kind of psychology is very simple which
is it's all about the value prop right
the second this show doesn't bring you
enough value you stop watching period
end of story and that's what it's all
about and so Twitter has a challenge of
making sure its product brings enough
value that the little things that maybe
don't bring you value still don't offset
the value event Gary my name is Raphael
I run the personal
development YouTube channel my question
to you is what would you do if you were
starting over and building your personal
brand all over again basically getting
the name garyvee out there all over
again in this day and age what would you
do to go out there and really spread the
word and to get yourself known I love
this question and boy I'm gonna set up
do I have a really good answer for this
because you and thanks for the question
and every other youngster needs to hear
this
really really loud and clear and this is
not being disrespectful because I was a
22 year old genius business person in my
mind because what I did but I would do
exactly what I did which is for the
first 10 years of my professional career
I didn't say a damn thing from 22 to 32
when it comes to business at 30 I
started Wine Library TV from 22 to 32
and one would argue that I was really
doing business since 14 but I'll just
say 22 because it was all in no school
fine from 22 to 32 my friend I did
nothing
in building the Gary Vaynerchuk brand
you know what I did I did the work that
allowed me to have the audacity to build
the Gary Vaynerchuk brand this notion
that you can just come out the gate and
build your brand by growth hacking and
putting yourself out there and getting
on some podcasts and leveraging other
people's brands to get on and build
yourself as an expert in what like when
are we going to start asking all these
people that are experts what did they do
here's what I did and why I think you
should listen to me in business I am now
in the midst of building my second 50
million dollar plus business within a
five-year window that's good execution
at a speed that most people can't
calibrate at a high volume app is it 50
billion no but it's a life right for a
lot of people its business I invested in
companies early on and made a lot of
money because I saw where the market was
going
hence the video I popped up earlier
before that's linked below of what I saw
with Apple pay I did things that allowed
me to start having a shot to be worthy
of people buying a fifteen dollar book
or spending fifteen minutes and watching
his or her show so I did things so my
fur
to you and everybody else I promise you
before you get your name out there it'd
be really nice that you can go to the
accomplishments because when I asked you
hey bro awesome that you're a branding
or health or personal coach or whatever
the hell you are but what do you do to
become good enough to do this I'd like
to I love when people argue with me on
this issue they're like well look at all
the football coaches these coaches a lot
of times are not real players you don't
give me a great football player to be a
great football coach guys have you
looked at every football coach there's
no football coach that comes out of
nowhere at 23 years old and is that an
NFL coach and win Super Bowls they've
been a bull boy since they were 7 and
worked it within the organization for 20
years 15 years be Eric Mangini when he
was a Jets coach at 36 have been a ball
boy stews 18 like like they're in it
forever their kids their sons and
daughters of coaches they've been in it
their whole lives that's how you get
there and so this quick move of using
good modern technology to build up your
brand siphoning and doing jayvees with
other people to siphon their brand
equity that you're passing on that I'm
an expert and then coming out the gate
and saying I'm an expert building rant
it's ludicrous I laugh at it in my soul
in my stomach and so does everybody
who's got chops I say one more time I
laugh at it and so does everybody that's
got chops and I need you to pay
attention to that you have to earn your
opportunity to be a personal brand and
the only way to do that is to actually
execute and so when somebody asks me
well what makes you a social media
experts expert I show them things I've
sold in sales business put money in the
pocket predicated on marketing within
that channel that's a way to do it that
I believe in my friends I really
appreciate you watching the show little
question of the day by the way really
disappointed with the vaynernation and
the veiny acts out there by the way
that's the question of the day do you
consider yourself in the vaynernation or
do you consider yourself a veiny AK and
can you also jump in and explain to me
the difference I need to figure this out
once and for all I go back and forth but
a very disappointing you guys I was
flabbergasted by the notion that I
didn't do a question of the day
the other day and I forgot and a lot of
people didn't do what I asked several
episodes ago which is just come in and
talk about the show we need more talking
in there I've noticed a couple of you
interacting with the rest of you in the
YouTube obviously comments for everybody
who's listening right now and I know
you're listening on the podcast and I
know you want to be audio first but the
show right now is a you know video first
you have got to respect that
and more portly you're capable of going
to YouTube and leaving a comment if
you'd like it's not you're like you're
crippled from just listening to it I
know you're in your car right now but
like when you get to the office instead
of sitting around and not doing in first
15 minutes go to youtube.com slash Gary
Vaynerchuk and leave a comment just want
to get that off my chest
anyway ah I need I need banter I got to
give it to the Wine Library TV community
an its gonna take his time we're just
starting but like without a question day
there was banter there was overall
banter my friends I need banter I like
banter
give me the banter I actually I actually
hit myself harder actually hit myself
harder than I want to show all right I'm
getting stronger oh crap wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe